لاول مره منذ بدايه هذه الحرب نتمكن من
الوصول لهذه المناطق هنا في شمال قطاع غزه
بعد انسحاب كامل لقوات الاحتلال والياته
من المناطق الغربيه لشمال قطاع غزه نشاهد
هنا حجم هذا الدمار نتيجه توغل قوات
الاحتلال في هذه المناطق هنا الشارع شارع
البحر شارع الرشيد تم تدميره بالكامل
وتدمير البنيه التحتيه الخاصه به ايضا
هناك كان عدد من المصا ومن المنازل في هذه
المنطقه تم تدميرها بالكامل ايضا تدمير
جميع المنتجعات السياحيه هنا في هذه
المنطقه طبعا هذه المنطقه كانت احد
المعالم السياحيه للمواطنين هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه كما نشاهد حجم الدمار الذي خلفته
قوات الاحتلال نتيجه هذا التوغل وهذا
القصف المستمر على هذه المناطق طبعا هناك
انسحاب كامل قوات الاحتلال من هذه المناطق
من منطقه الوام وال عطاطره والسلاطين
انسحاب بالك حتى منطقه زكيم لا يتواجد اي
من قوات الاحتلال في هذه المناطق الان
طبعا حجم الدمار طال الاف المنازل امتدادا
من هذا الشارع وحتى منطقه العطاطه وتوام
والسلاطين الاف المنازل دمرت نتيجه هذا
القصف ونتيجه هذا التوغل